sa 4e visite à l'Ukraine depuis le début
de l'invasion russe Anthony blinken et
donc arrivé ce matin à Kiev où il doit
passer selon les informations de
Washington Post deux jours le diplomate
américain a été accueilli tout à l'heure
vous allez découvrir les premières
images par le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne Nitro couliba je vous
propose d'écouter tout de suite le
secrétaire d'État américain réitérer le
soutien indéfectible de Washington à
l'Ukraine
je suis ici avant tout pour témoigner de
notre soutien constant et déterminé à
l'Ukraine face à cette agression
nous avons constaté des progrès notables
dans la contre-offensive
ce qui est très encourageant
nous voulons nous assurer que l'Ukraine
dispose de ce dont elle a besoin non
seulement pour réussir la
contre-offensive mais aussi pour
s'assurer à long terme qu'elle dispose
d'une forte capacité de dissuasion et de
défense pour que l'avenir de tels
agressions ne se reproduisent plus
Bruno Darro bonjour voilà pour les
projets les premières images soutient
indéfectibles aurait été ré- à l'Ukraine
soutien qui se concrétise par l'annonce
imminente d'un nouveau soutien financier
c'est ce qui est annoncé en tout cas un
nouveau soutien financier qui devrait
tourner autour de 1 milliard de dollars
un soutien financier alors militaire
bien sûr également pour aider l'Ukraine
à passer l'hiver
d'un point de vue énergétique que
l'Ukraine est suffisamment d'énergie en
quelque sorte pour passer ces mois
difficiles qui s'annoncent et puis aussi
une partie pour commencer à constituer
un portefeuille qui est déjà bien
constitué mais pour déjà pouvoir entamer
la reconstruction du pays donc vous
voyez c'est une approche à la fois
militaire mais aussi une approche pour
une perspective de paix future si vous
voulez et entamer d'ores et déjà la
reconstruction alors une aide d'un
milliard de dollars ça nécessite pas
forcément un déplacement à Kiev Anthony
blinken il y a une aide de 3 milliards
qui a été débloquée récemment de toute
façon on le sait les États-Unis reste et
de très loin le principal créancier en
quelque sorte de l'Ukraine pour l'aider
à la fois dans son effort militaire son
effort économique son effort de
reconstruction pour l'avenir voilà alors
je vais multiplie parce qu'il s'agit
aussi de montrer qu'on est là sur le
terrain que les Américains ne lâcheront
pas les
Ukrainiens dans le contexte actuel
électoral qu'on connaît oui voilà en
fait ce déplacement qui est donc le
quatrième déplacement d'Anthony blinken
à Kiev c'est la première fois il faut le
noter qu'il va passer une nuit en
Ukraine ça c'est
visé ce matin par les Russes
on ne sait pas par les Russes ce matin
bon finalement il n'y a pas eu de
blessés
ni de ni de dégâts conséquent mais enfin
bon en tout cas c'est ces deux
événements sont concomitants mais
surtout effectivement on est dans un
contexte où aux États-Unis en période
électorale il y a des doutes sur cet
effort très important quand même des
États-Unis depuis le début de l'invasion
russe on est tous types de financement
confondus au delà quand même des cent
milliards et il y a des doutes et des
interrogations alors certes qui sont
présents chez les républicains sont
sondage indiqué que 72 % des électeurs
républicains ne souhaitaient pas
continuer cet effort pour Kiev mais il y
a aussi des interrogations chez des
responsables démocrates et chez les
sympathisants les électeurs démocrates à
un niveau global dans toute l'opinion
publique américaine c'est à peu près 55%
des Américains qui disent là ça nous
coûte trop cher pour un résultat qui
n'apparaît pas évident il y a eu la
semaine dernière des responsables de
l'administration Biden sous couvert
d'anonymat qui se sont exprimés dans la
presse en disant cette contre-offensive
qui a débuté il y a trois mois on ne
sait pas très bien où ça va etc ce qui
fait d'ailleurs que le ministre des
Affaires étrangères Ukrainiens du métro
couliba qu'on a aperçu à l'antenne avait
eu une réaction assez ferme en leur
demandant je cite de la fermer et
devenir sur le terrain pour voir comment
on peut gagner quelques centimètres donc
il y avait de la tension y compris avec
l'administration Biden d'où cette visite
d'Anthony blinken une visite
essentiellement politique pour délivrer
donc le message suivant ne vous
inquiétez pas les États-Unis sont là
pour vous soutenir financièrement et ce
soutien va être constant et déterminé
comme vient de le dire Anthony blinken
voilà et puis d'autres d'autres
déclarations on imagine un conférence de
presse qu'on attend évidemment qu'on
vous fera vivre en direct sur cette
antenne Anthony mingen qui doit
également être reçu rencontrer volody
mire volody mirzelinski on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir merci beaucoup
Bruno